good morning evelyn
fine i found a lake shirt
i learned how to embroidery on christmas
day 1972.
really yup
it turned into a backyard garden
uh i have got stoma down
tell me judy she used to walk
up and down the street scrubbing toilets
she was age 69 when she was born
she's from atlanta
it wasn't named ordered until i was born
i was at georgia peace when i was about
uh nine years old
don't mind if i light it up no go ahead
where did you grow up evelyn kennewick
washington
i moved to benton county when i got a
birth certificate
i was three years old from 37 that was
all i had
tell me about your mom and dad well my
mom
was a handicapped
right servant that's what she called it
and she wrote down the word right and i
went to college that day to a local
library and
started studying science why sugar was
needed made and um
and clothes and i found
this braided bread and i ate all of it
it was a sugar donut i brought it home
and two more of them appeared
i had a kitchen counter with little gold
stars on it
but we got a teapot for christmas in
1978.
that thing was very dangerous my dad
took it down to the desert and seeing
our neighbors shot it with a rifle
those were the first eyes in our
neighborhood
yeah our legs were very ungainly
that was the only bread for about four
months
with those three braided sugar rolls
somehow cinnamon got into my guest
coffee's been here since 1801.
those coffee leads with the separation
means a sign of peace
but it has the bubble gum as part of it
that comes from petroleum and
little schools it holds the top of the
food in
so you can see inside parts of the body
i don't think you can see inside
everything
everything is everything i was told that
in new york the next day
somebody handed me a glass of champagne
and i saw prima ballerina
they were so thin but their legs were
nice
and they all went there was about
six seven or eight of them and i found a
quarter behind one of the
pink slippers and i saw the heels of it
they have
wood in their toes very painful
anyway i i got up and they all gasped
and i found raspberry yogurt
they didn't have a label but as i rubbed
the quarter against it to keep my
fingers from being frozen
i thought there was a lot of land and
that it was always christmas
or cold that was my third night in new
york city
i went there to become a writer
because i knew that the east coast has
very
little food than a lot of people
also more new yorkers get married than
anyone else
chicago rates highest in divorce
separated families
welfare started in 1936 the same year as
the dewey decimal system
the libraries came about come about over
three years
i'll be around about
pinocchio yeah that man who assaulted me
this morning i
went to a movie with him and he ordered
a caramel bar
and ate it in front of the exit doors
i think about being touched on the nose
by a light bulb
that is what you'd see if you peg down
on chocolate in front of a theater kid
my jacket's going out of style i've lost
a lot of waldos paper bags are related
to red hair
but you're mine anyway because i used to
fill up sacks of candy for
my friends on holidays we had three
or just two halloweens together we
eating gumball after gumballs sweet
tarts we never heard of teeth or sugar
or bum
or anything like that and they had
rotten teeth by the time we were seven
years old
but i went to private school for three
years before i learned about jesus
we'd run and took balls and the teachers
would watch us
they were a reflection off of bowling
pins there was a bowling alley that we
retreated to the evening
it had 21 lanes of bowling
that's before numbers 1 2 3 4
51.
i had a big hunk that was all i ate for
lunch for
about four years those nuts
were softened that's when people were
really scared
i know the feeling
but you can't carry it with you
i was voted democratic recycling
committee chairperson
and uh it was the bush was elected
president the next day
that was my first day of black and white
television
i thought the world had died because i
was
i started watching television when i was
two days old
i saw it bewitched samantha stevens
somehow i got into kindergarten and
paying the flag my arms were real short
and they were puffed up so they took me
to a hospital
and laid me under cool sheets and gave
me strawberry sherbet a little glass of
root beer and i kept that glass for 18
years
it made my kitchen counter when i took
it down i was 16 then
i just gotten home from hawaii i was
being hooked out then
when one didn't come to class we ran
down the street and i met a woman named
mrs
lippert and she fed me for the day the
next day a woman
flew in from wisconsin she was hoping to
be a nurse that's what i saw
and she became my mother
it's it's hard to record details of life
when you're
uh
just home from the hospital
one man had a bump on his head inside
but i did get some sleep and get to wash
my feet
my body uh
got to read mark twain how to paint a
fence
did some push-ups and jumping jacks
watched television for 18 hours
that's six days saw b
scenes bottles of wine a nice defeated
dress with black lace
saw my mom's living room yeah
yeah when i found out that i had a mom i
smiled to myself and i always have to
get my secret
most people don't know what a secret is
that that would be a personal flesh
item but i had cancer i was i was on a
life support
i only had legs as i walked up with
terrell street i wasn't interested in
the front of my body
that was my second afternoon in san
francisco
it was really hot the sun was blazing
and going everywhere
people were eating bagels coffee
spilling
recycling i did that at peach coffee and
they denied me a raisin
bagel i finally found
a jar of sour cream
and a man split his bagel with me then
he asked for a bath but i
i didn't get it to him i felt so bad i
thought i'd started to death
but i found him outside the door and we
took a taxi ride up to the cadillac
market
they just had one door in there but they
did have a cash machine
made from taxi stores that silver
made by water soft drinks
white socks pink vagina apples pieces
pumpkin pie
then i went to mcdonald's are you a good
cook i like grease
i can take hot temperatures in cooking
but cool soda is my favorite
but it's hard to be away from the world
that's what drinking does
takes away
[Music]
yeah i was in barn like the fifth day in
san francisco it turned the evening
really rapidly
and the bus stop went in where people
were
almost dead you know they'd been on
earth for about 65 hours
without a juice or anything so i bought
a cranberry juice and
a stack of styrofoam cups and that day i
found out that
seal containers make you hard of hearing
later that same year i was behind
cardboard a man stacked up where he
thought was a homeless
he nearly murdered me i nearly lost
my right breast which is milk and a
creamery diet
i had a jar of cool cream
that i drank the whole thing and i
started training for the olympics that
afternoon i was 12 years old
i finally got flesh on my face before i
hit my bones
i was in the movie else in years when i
was 18 i was sad
and i was so ugly that i scared people
about 12 that's your formative years
that's about the time you start
worrying about the world events comes
next
i saw nbc programming and i watched 60
minutes that night
and i saw drug dealing now people would
bust into your house in uniform and
just stand there and the fat people
those are the saddest people on earth
that means someone in their life is
crying or they are
but water is part of tears so you should
drink it
so that you can
have a grape or something like that
that sustained me for four hours that i
waited in front of the office for a
check or a
glass of soup
that's about hooking in new orleans i
was 15 years old then on my
way to become a navy seal but i got
rained out of the bus and
and the uniformed man came in and
let me board to montana and i worked
there for seven months to pay for a
backpack
and a bowling bat to take into the army
that he was uniformed i thought that was
handsome i liked the color green and
gold and black
it was laced it was dignified
that was the first uniform i saw then i
came home that night my dad had on the
10
road i thought wow you really do have to
share clothes
i thought what was that other thought
and all i could think of was love with
the giving thing is my dad tied the robe
around his thin way
he was just getting it together then but
he lost it the next morning
and i was so young i had never heard of
food or eggs or cracking open
or hard work so he bought me a bike for
17 cents
he made it from his bottle caps people
thought they were running
slave hand i learned magic that day
my friend she was my gymnast partner
she used to watch me we'd do stretches
together and i locked her legs and upper
[ __ ] and i saw go there
and that was my first uh
uh range uh sports equipment
yeah that was all the clothes we had
with shorts someone come in with just a
white t-shirt and we thought that was
cool
until the shower started running and
people were
streaked with water then no oil
afterwards
i remember that day now my skin so dry
i ran down the road ready to just kill
someone
and i said someone is us and there was a
deli there
a fine restaurant that would be if
you're starving and
a home from my school i called
restaurants at a school too because you
will learn what people look like from
what they can do
and by eating with them that can take
seven hours
what's your favorite food
broccoli noodles with spiced beef
i had a garlic farm it was 12 acres
that next night i went to the beach and
it turned morning in four
hours i had to walk through grass i met
two girls there one was behind me one
was in front of me
i put it on my back i didn't know the
word lifting weights but i learned that
day
she had a little sports uh backyard
we built a hot tub with boys legs
we were nearly murdered for doing that
as we boarded the ferry
they came at us with an axe and darts
and everything
that's what that redwood made we stayed
out of hot tubs
and as i was so exhausted and so on my
own i hadn't made it yet there was just
17 people in the world
i went around poking a taxi window on my
way to a hot tub
that man had invited me he drank water
and he wouldn't give me any so i put my
hand on his knee and squeezed it and
then he became a happy camper
i think that's probably when you came
into existence
he's healthy he's your friend i laid on
that table
and he put a warm towel on my back and i
slept for 17 hours
and revived ready to take on the world i
walked downtown saw the opera center
burial mountain there i thought the
world was
not in very good shape i walked without
water
so i went on a 12-mile hike up to
general hospital seeking hills that i
know the water runs downhill
and all i had was a roast beef sandwich
very thirsty so i asked for a token
and the world was still so low they gave
it to me i shot a mcdonald's and ordered
a car
never heard of money being paid for for
by a
dying person and she gave me the calls
and she came over to the table and her
hips made a man named james cowan
now mcdonald's is responsible for
putting in videos for
delayed syndrome you take the bus i'll
go shopping the kid's born
you delayed syndrome you better meet up
somehow
stand outside the door and show them
your leg or your coat
camel hair coat town clothing will make
your head run if you're
if you're a burnout girl brunette is
usually the love of spicy food and late
night
probably one room though only dark hair
when cardboard first appeared that's the
first day i
gave up my birth certificate i had done
15 jumping jacks knowing that you had to
entertain yourself when
when the world was wrong
and it was there were no maps and bus
stops
just that one down involved but that was
shaken by rain and snow
evelyn what's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
uh
not to mix marriage and pleasure
if you want to marry someone just say
um would you like an orange and if they
don't want the orange and they're not
right for you
because your mind is the right one
[Music]
that was my leaving of home i saw those
thoughts and wrote it down
on the postcard and my dad kept that
letter
when i came home from the army i still
wanted to be a navy seal
i went down the road and there was a
gigantic pool and i died and i had a
terrific
afternoon as i climbed out two women
were born when
13 one was two years old
and she's still very fragile
i went to la the next day so cool from
the pool
it was just 34 miles away from the pool
but that was before clock so i thought
it was three and a half miles
i walked into a front yard and the door
slammed and closed and slammed and
closed
and i didn't know the word hurt or
kidnapping or murder or anything like
that
i thought i was still going to be
refreshed or saved
and i wanted to touch the door and go
into a home and meet people
to tell them about the pool and what a
fine day i had
i touched a lot and a woman looked out a
square
window and she scared me to death i ran
all the way home and cried against the
neighbor's window
and i played as a seven-year-old putting
my fingers on my hand pretending i was a
horse
ran around in the grass until it burned
went next door almost ready to kill
for shoes that's how angry children can
be when they're neglected
but somebody will write them they may
get a broken cheekbone from
somebody who's homeless most people
don't have any fastenings
i was i became a president of the
democratic chairman committee when i
when i founded my um
when i found a public school library
that was the first word i saw
pres and written form
what do you think of our president
i like clinton he's from the south he
eats good
and his college partner hillary is not
his wife that's his college partner
bill clinton and hillary
he's kind of a professor guy but he's
more of a farmer and a lazy fat ass
he's a redneck so with jimmy carter
somebody hard work knives spoons spoons
not very interesting to men
forks you'll make a clock you can eat
beans and
laxative foods beans heat up in fields
they'll grow understand and
find their way out if you keep walking
if you go barefoot
let your feet get salt on them from the
earth the way people move
most people are in tears but panic
attached to the worm
or salt to the face back neck or leg
ankle toe
so i took ballet lessons for seven hours
i paid 15 cents
that my dad had given me swimming water
in my bikini
i that was my only friend for 13 years
was that yellow polka dot bikini yeah
pink flowers one was down here where my
breasts weren't even one's big
but they're still nice if boys like
sweet icing i won a cakewalk when i
was seven years old i was taking to
school to see
why the teacher would come back that was
all the thought we had
i thought that's very good i found
sports equipment and played in my
backyard batman with nets that made the
saudi arabian tent
so i took it on i rode my bike to the
desert
bikes were free back then we'd trade
them we'd find them all over the place
they changed from orange to purple to
red they were real pretty
you just see the end of red in the
evening i remember that night
black black has been here that's part of
car the earth melting and moving
i walked across a
volcano easter has existed since
1 bc that's the edge of the ocean
you can't find shells down there that's
what you have to give to someone for a
holiday or to praise them
i started singing as i found cardboard
it was layered up i thought it was
interesting because i've always known
that song james brown
well i have since new orleans
i was kept from going on the bus
because it had no seats
they were being used in schools
yeah but we were chased by ashes for
putting up that hot tub
with boys legs that they were just lying
all over the floor
so i learned creation theory in the
forest
they just had two inches of water i
my brother wanted to go to college he
left that afternoon for arizona and his
truck
for some reason he likes gasoline evelyn
do you believe in god
yeah i do not all the time
i get too worn out he probably does too
it can be just a piece of food that
you're missing
but you'll feel better if you stay away
from words like
uh flower power stuff like that that'll
make you walk
into someone because everybody likes
a nice person but that'll make you
a real festive i've learned that people
are not loyal they get a sunburn
forrest gump he's even though he's a
black man he's redneck
and he likes girls he'll give them their
props
props hair brushes candy bars let them
look in there
look at his black socks his mismatches
[Music]
there always be an answer
then i wasn't see i was selling uh i was
in two places at one time
one i was a cashier i saw the caster and
it didn't interest me at all
because i had so few clothes suddenly i
was in portland and my sister appeared
i'd seen her marriage she and her
husband are still in love
they own a farm and she milks cows and
raises goats
that's her private life because i
reached out i was missing her to say
goodbye
to violence and she said if you talk to
dear
i speak differently in her because i'm
three years
uh younger than her in college years
but she was born 83 months before me on
christmas eve 1956.
my mother was so happy i remember her
face i was
i was two years old that happens i do
not know
probably the fat on my mother's arms
from her breathtaking
she's from montana
evelyn would you like me to take you
back i don't want to wear you out
yeah sure i don't want you get too tired
maybe we'll do this again tomorrow okay
cool thank you darling that was
wonderful
sure it's always fun listening to you
thank you